[Music]
with diverse indigenous African and
European roots
Havana's culture and architecture
reflect Cuba's complex history of
conquest slavery liberation and
revolution
[Music]
chosen for its strategic location on the
islands northwestern coast in the early
16th century the city grew into the
largest port in Spain's Caribbean
colonies the original layout of Havana
Vieja Old Havana
is still intact building ordinances in
the 19th and 20th centuries preserved
the city's architectural integrity
wrought iron gates historic statues and
stone balconies adorned its five main
plazas among some 900 surrounding
historic buildings a few highlights
include the Castillo de la Royale fuerza
one of the oldest existing forts in the
Americas the 18th century catedral de la
havana on the plaza by the same name and
the museo de la ciudad housed in a
baroque palace on Havana's original town
square even with international
recognition the work of preserving the
historic city centre remains ongoing
[Music]
visitors from around the world flock to
Havana for its exciting nightlife and a
fascinating blended cultural heritage of
art music and design traveling to Cuba
is much easier for US citizens than it
used to be but check the State
Department website for any current
advisory notices
[Music]